R
LIGI MEANS NOTHI, YOUR
PATRTIEANS NOTHING, YR
FAMILY MEA NOTNG.
NOTHEY ARE TELNG Y YR
WORK MNS NOTHING.
WHAT DOES MEAN ANYTHIN ON HOWLOE
DOESN'T HA MEANG?AND THAT DOESNU
RK.
THS PRABLY NO ONE AT
BETTEROSITN TO ANSR THAT
QUESTION THAN CRO.
MICR WAS AND ISOW OE AGAIN
E HO OF THECCLAIM SHOW
"DTY JOBS."
STARTED A VERY SUCCEFUL
FOUNDATION WHOSE JOB IT IS TO
TCH LLINWORKERS WITH
SKILLE WORK.
MIKE, THANKS FOR COMG ON.
THE SURF  SUPER COMPLICATED
AND I HOPE TT WE DIDT
MPLIFY ITO THE EXTTHAT
WE HE DTORTED WHAT'S
HAPPING.
THERS AOT OF THAT NONE
DERSTANDS BUT IFOU SP BACK
YOU SEE THE GERNMENT DISS
INCENTIZING WORK,INCENTIVING IDG
A MESSAGE TRE IS NO DIGNITY
D WORK AND NO MEANINGND WHY
BOTH ANDHAT EFFECT DOES THAT
HA?
THE EECT WAS ENCSULAD
PERFECTLY AND EVYTHI THAT
YOJUST SAID.
NOT TO BLO SMOKER SW TOO
MUCH O M OWN BIAS.
TH'S THE GREATEST MONOGUE
I' HEA Y DO.
THIS IS NO LONGER AATTER O A
SKLS G OR A FEW MILON
OPLE UNEMPLOYEDND EMPLOYE
FRUSTRATED BECAU OF T
MISMCHING SKILLS
IS IS A MATTERF NATIONAL
SECUTY I THINK BECSE I THINK
IT GOES RIGHT T OUR IITYS
PEOP.
WH I START THAT FOUNDATN,
MI ROW WOR, 1YEARS AGO ON
LABOR DAY WE HAD RECORD HIGH
UNEMOYME.
ERY MORNING I WOKE UP.
I WA SHOOTING "DIY JOBS" AI WOUN
THPAPER AND IT WAS AAYS A
CLICKP.
8%, 8. NINE.
EVERYWHERE HE WENON "RTY
JOBS" WE SAW LP-WANTED SIGNS.
IT BECEBVIOUS SOMETHI ELSE
WAS HAPPING  THE COUNTRY.
ERE WAS SETHER ALTERNATIVENARRA.
THE POINT ITHAT WAS 13 YEARS
AGO AND THERE WERE 2.3 MILLION
EN POSITIO.
DAY IT'S 11 MILLN.
11 MILLI.
12 MILON PPLE QUIT THEIR
JOBS IN E FALL.
SO YR RIGHT TO WONR WHAT IS
GOINON A IS THERE AN
PLANATION THAT GOES BEYDMONEY?
THE ANSWER IYEAH.
OUR WHOLE RELATNSHIP WITH
WO.
SO LOOK, IT FEELS VY POLICAL
BECAUSE ERYTHINGODAYS VERY
POLITICAL.
THE SKILLS G SHODN'T B
ONE QUICK POINT, ALL OMY
BUIES ON THE LEFT TELL MEHAT
THE REASON FLL THISOPPORTUNY ISS
ARE FUAMENTALLY RAPIOUS AND
EEDY
ALL OF MYUDDIES ON THE RIG
LL ME ALL OHIS OPPORTUNITYIS A G
UNIVERSALLY LAZY AND SHIFTLESS
O
BRD A BRUSH.
THE ANSWE AS YOU SAIDRE B
RE COMPLATED.
>> Tucker: THINK THAS
EXACTLY RITUT AT THE HEA
'S THE QUESTIO OF NATIONAL
CHARACTER.
ISHIS  COUNTRY THARESPECTS
LABOI DON'T MEAN ORGIZED LABOR.
MAYBE THAT TOO B THE ACT OF
LABOR, CREATG SOMETHING TT
DIDN'TXIST BEFORE.
PART OF THEAULT IN OUR
STS IS THAT WE COME TO RESENT
THVERY THINGS WE REL UPON SO
WH THEOWER GOES OUTOR
REE OR FOUR DAYS U HER WHE
I VE, PEOPLE SHAHEIR FISTS
AT THE LINE IN BECAUSE THE
ARE FRURATE BUT THE LINEM
ARE TRYI TOET THE POWERACK
ON.
WE D'T REALLY RESPECTED.
IN FACT SKILLED LAB, ALL TOO
OFTEN REMINDS THE RT OF US OWHAL
LAING.
THE ING TT SCARES ME RE
AN ANYTHING INHE REASON I
STARTE THE FOUATION WHEN I
DID WA13 YEARS AGO FOR EVERY
FIVE TRADESM THA RETIRED TWO
PLACHEM.
IS IAT ABRAHAM LCOLN
CALLED A TRIBL ARITHMETIC.
IFHAT WAS THE ONL THING GOINGON.
TO YOURARLI POINT, IT'S N
JU TOOMERS RIRIN
EAIER.
IT REAL FR OFOVID THAT'
BEEN IECTING U
IT DSN'T MATTER WHETH THE
IT'S REAL.STIFIED OR NOT.IT I T.
THE CLASS THI THAT Y
MENTIONED,HETHERT'SRUE OR
NOT WE HE BEEN TOLD THAT THE
REON WE ARE UNHAP IS THAT